at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half-mile before my hands shake this
episode is brought to you by fresh books
fresh books has become the go-to cloud
accounting software for literally
millions of small business owners who
found a faster more efficient and much
less stressful way to deal with their
numbers and ultimately this helps you to
focus on what you are best at it is used
by many of the fastest growing startups
I've invested in or advised and it's
equally used by many of the best
freelancers I work with on a daily or
weekly basis it is one of the easiest
ways to send invoices get paid track
your time and track your clients if
you're self-employed and managing
business sometimes means wrestling with
spreadsheets crumpled receipts and other
scattered pieces fresh books can really
help fresh books allows you to do many
many different things very easily
preparing and sending a polished branded
invoice takes about 30 seconds you can
set yourself up to receive online
payments from your clients in about two
clicks which on average will get you
paid twice as fast their new proposals
feature means you can include a project
summary and timeline as part of your
estimate there are many many other
things
tracking your time the quick proposals
that I mentioned formatting free
super-easy late payment reminders you
don't have to chase people automatic
expenses sharing files and messages with
your clients award-winning customer
service they are extremely responsive
the interface is super intuitive and
there's almost no learning curve
so in short it's easy it saves you time
and right now fresh books is offering an
unrestricted 30-day free trial for all
of my listeners to claim yours check it
out go to FreshBooks dot-com forward
slash tim and enter tim ferriss in the
how did you hear about a section and
that is funky spell t IM f e RR is s so
again go to fresh books comm forward
slash tim and enter tim ferriss and how
did you hear about us section check it
out
this episode is brought to you by
LegalZoom which more than 2 million
Americans have used to help start their
businesses past guests even such as
while WordPress lead developer CEO of
automatic Matt Mullenweg now valued at
more than a billion dollars have used
LegalZoom to help with their business
needs specifically in his case to form
his company but LegalZoom isn't just for
launching your business their services
include everything from helping you to
manage changing tax laws reviewing
contracts creating NDA's non-disclosure
agreements important stuff handling
lease agreements and assisting with
really any other legal challenge hurdle
inconvenience that typically takes time
and effort away from running your
business the best part is that you won't
get charged by the hour
because LegalZoom isn't a law firm so
they won't be running the clock up and
spinning circles just to raise your bill
instead they just ask you to pay one low
upfront price for whatever it is that
you're looking to get all a cart style
so visit legalzoom.com and check out
their business section for all their
services and if you want special savings
that's the terminology and the copy that
they suggest I don't know what the
special savings is folks but its
titillating if you want special savings
enter promo code Tim T I am at checkout
capital T lower case I am again take a
peek legalzoom.com and enter promo code
to him
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show where it is my job to
interview and deconstruct world class
performers of all different types from
business sports military chess you name
it science we bounced all over the place
and this episode is going to be
wide-ranging not only focused on
business or investing although we do
have an all-star in both of those arenas
the guest is Scott Belsky he is one of
the people I call most for advice on a
wide range of topics who's scott at
Twitter at Scott Belsky BLS KY Scott
Belsky calm scott is an entrepreneur
author investor and currently chief
product officer of Adobe big big company
might have heard of it he is also a
venture partner at benchmark one of the
most famous venture capital firms
anywhere but this one based in San
Francisco
Scott co-founded Behance in 2006 and
served as CEO until Adobe acquired
Behance in 2012 millions of people used
Behance to display their portfolios as
well as track and find top talent across
creative industries he is also a
incredibly successful early stage
investor and advisor who has been
involved with companies like Pinterest
uber periscope among many many other
fast-growing startups and his latest
project is a compendium of insights and
tactics for what Scott calls the messy
middle we all know we have that initial
euphoric start to big projects or
companies and then you enter what you
might have heard of in perhaps incubator
parlance in this case Y Combinator I
believe we first stood as the the trough
of sorrow so you have this initial burst
of adrenaline and then there is a long
middle period with any type of creative
endeavor that can get really messy and
that is where a lot of people give up or
get destroyed in one fashion or another
and then there are people who make it to
the last mile and ultimately complete
many of these projects or have some type
of acquisition or exit with the startup
so this episode covers a lot of ground
we talked about a lot of these tactics
and if for whatever reason you're
thinking you
what I want to listen to this Scott
sounds interesting but I don't want to
focus exclusively on business stuff or
business building don't worry there's a
lot in here that transcends that and
specifically we shift locations a number
of times in this episode we end up in
the sauna at one point and if you want a
real-life example of how I asked my
friends for help because I was getting
all wound up about a very very top of
mine situation when Scott showed up in
my house jump about 55 minutes ahead
from where we begin the interview so the
easiest way to do that if you want to
that's when we are in the sauna and I
asked him for help is as soon as we
start kind of hop an hour into the audio
or so and then jump back like five
minutes and it should be around there
but there's a ton of stuff that you can
mine out of this interview Scott is a
great guy and I had a blast hanging with
him and with that I will let you also
through your ears hang with none other
than Scott Belsky Scott welcome to the
show thanks Tim here we are at the
kitchen table I didn't think we would
have a chapter two today we met earlier
for some oysters and beverages and
caught up and I was picking your brain
on a number of different things and we
were trading stories and I realized that
you have and you're gonna know what I'm
referring to
how many Evernote notes well a lot of
Evernote notes but specific to what
we'll be talking about yeah I think it
was this it started at maybe 830 or so a
couple years ago when I started trimming
it down and you've been capturing
lessons learned
Maxim's mantras for yourself in the
process of developing this career and
hope this doesn't come off the wrong way
but you've worn so many hats it isn't a
single career it seems like you've lived
many different lives and people have
already heard the bio that I read in the
intro but
so you could indicate the roles that
you've had in the companies that you've
been a part of because they are so
varied and I just want to underscore how
eclectic it is yeah collecting for
better or for worse but I was an
entrepreneur back in 2005 starting a
very small almost a lifestyle business
at that point to help organize the
creative world a company called behance
five years of bootstrapping
as a small team valuing resourcefulness
over the resources we didn't have a few
near-death experiences in that process
then became a venture-backed company
which is a little bit more of a
traditional Silicon Valley like story
being venture backed for a few years
growing really fast went through an
acquisition then started found myself
working in a very big company as a vice
president given what I came in with as
well as a few other projects and a few
new muscles there navigating a big big
corporate experience then I decided he
know it I've been a seed investor for a
while I like this people are telling me
I should be an investor jumped in and
became a general partner at a venture
capital firm total context switch
learned a lot of things I'm the hard way
then realized I miss building I want to
get back to it now I'm an executive at a
big public company I'd be the same
company that acquired us but totally new
position and I would say that whenever I
think about best practices if there was
ever such a thing or I actually realized
that they all conflict based on whatever
context you're in and the things that I
thought were super important as a
startup and and where the the rules of
the road if you will actually maybe the
exact wrong playbook to play at a later
stage company or then at a public
company or an eventual capital firm and
it in some ways makes you kind of throw
everything you accept as conventional
wisdom out the door because you realize
that everything kind of conflicts and
it's really based on the context but in
some ways there are also some patterns
and some lessons learned from the
clashes of of wisdom and the the
different positions that you've
to the different roles you have played
are also of interest to me because
you've ended up filling the seats on
both sides of the table in different
relationships and different transactions
right entrepreneur investor start-up
founder and potential acquirer right I
mean you're in a position yourself now
where your younger self could have been
in some capacity talking to you yes and
you've collected these notes over time
so I thought what the hell and that we
talked about this maybe or maybe not
after a few glasses of wine uh-huh but
earlier today we should just record a
podcast so here we are late night at
Chez Ferris and we're gonna record this
episode at half of which may occur
inside a very very hot truth barrel ie
barrel sauna TBD
but we're just gonna wing it so so let's
let's start exploring some of these
these max I'm some of these notes and
you can tell us the story behind it
yeah and we're just gonna gonna riff so
let's do it sure well I have to say when
I started to it was actually on a plane
a couple years ago I was going through
this file of about eight hundred and
somethin notes and I realized that first
of all if this plane goes down they're
all gone and and second of all this is
really disorganized should I start to
kind of organize them based on some
theme and ultimately it came down to
three things one was endurance how do
you navigate the endless self-doubt
uncertainty ambiguity extraordinary
volatility in in whether it's a new
venture or a turnaround of something or
a bold creative project I feel like a
lot of them that was the theme like how
do you just stick with it with it long
enough to figure it out how do you have
the persistence and the patience and
everything related to endurance the
second theme that came out which is a
pretty broad theme I would say and maybe
I was cheating a little bit is
optimization you know how do you make
the product better how do you make the
team better and also how are you
constantly in some ways a be testing the
way you work and making yourself better
and you know obviously sure books could
be written on
but that was my second theme the third
theme which is a bit more narrow I
called the final mile
I found that whether it was
entrepreneurs I've worked with over the
years that that involved me in their
acquisition process or or writers that I
know right before their book comes out
people in the final mile of something
being done we're almost being done
there's a lot of interesting stuff that
happens some self-sabotage new doubts
you think you you know what you're doing
because you got that far and then you
realize oh I don't know what I'm
doing so that those were the three
themes and I was like okay for starters
let me just start to break them into
themes and that's where it all began
mm-hmm so you got the buckets let's
let's dig into some examples sure no so
I think that um you know if we go in
that order and you think about endurance
one of the one one of the there were a
number of different observations around
and especially for my own experience
building a circuit and bootstrapping for
five years and keeping people when we
actually weren't really making any money
we didn't really have customers no one
really cared about or knew about what we
were doing and you said organizing the
creative world I think may have been the
wording you use what is what does that
mean in practice like what were you
trying to sell yeah for behance
we the insight was that the creative
world meaning any sort of design
photographer architect illustrate or any
in the world of of creative production
these are some of the most interesting
people in the world they make our lives
interesting it's also the most
disorganized community on the planet
there's very little attribution about
who did what these folks oftentimes feel
like their careers at the mercy of
circumstance and the idea behind Behance
which was my startup back in the day was
to help organize these people in some
ways build a LinkedIn for the creative
world you could describe it that way and
some of the products to help them get
organized and we didn't really know what
we were doing it was a bit of a team of
misfits in the sense that all of us had
roles we weren't necessarily qualified
for when we were building this team in
the early days and what I learned very
quickly was that the the idea that we
wanted to
come together for that thing that
motivated us to in some ways in some in
some cases quit our jobs or take huge
risk or start incurring more debt in our
lives that was enough to get us to get
started that wasn't enough to keep us
engaged on a daily basis for years and I
think that's a you know one of those
myths that if the vision for what you
want to achieve in the long term is
great enough you know you can just keep
persisting and keep at it
in fact you need to short-circuit your
reward system in some ways and I
remember there was a conference we had a
number of years ago for Behance where
Fred Wilson venture capitals in New York
spoke and he talked about two great
addictions in life heroin and a weekly
salary and his point was when you unplug
from either one it's very difficult and
and if you think about from birth or
almost oriented towards short term
rewards checks on the test grades and
the courses salary bonus and whatever
and when you embark on something very
long-term and you unplugged from that
maybe you have to supplement it with
something else that is a creative
endeavor when you're leading a team me
for us there were a few fun things we
did I mean for starters we had a name
for our company called Behance which
didn't mean anything didn't exist and so
in every type everywhere every time he
typed it in Google it said do you mean
enhance do you mean and hints and so
short-term reward number one was maybe
we won't be a mistake someday let's get
enough people to put portfolios up there
let's get enough blog post and link
backs and whatever else and and we would
always search the ansan see if we
actually showed up it felt like a more
achievable you know way to keep us
oriented and and soon enough like we
actually did suddenly you know show up
as a legitimate result and I kid you not
like six months later Beyonce became
super popular if you loved it but then
we go back there were all kinds of fun
things like that we made bets all the
time about things that people would have
to do if we got to a certain milestone
and those became this like this this new
reward system that govern it actually
kept us together and we remarkably
didn't really lose many people at least
voluntarily for for a number of years
what else do you attribute that to and
for people who are listening
they might have a small team and they're
in that position of realizing perhaps
that the initial irrational exuberance
of the big vision and the the grand
unveiling of this world-changing company
is actually going to take quite a few
years and that people are starting to
likeness a founder but realize the
gravity of that reality is beginning to
hit them and the CEO may be sold out or
maybe co-founders thinking oh I
need to whip up some shorter term
incentives or motivating goals or
anything to keep this team together so
there isn't some form of mutiny or
people just are dropping off do you have
any recommendations for that person a
few different things you know in some
ways I use the analogy of driving your
team in a car with the windows blacked
out so no one knows where they are and
how far they are in the journey and that
is sort of what a start-up experience is
like by the way you don't know where
those milestones actually are you don't
necessarily even know where you're going
and how far along you are the only thing
that makes that more comforting or
tolerable is is a great narrative during
the journey okay you know we just
crossed the state line oh you know there
is this on the right there's this on the
Left even if it's not necessarily
answering the question of well how far
are we and where exactly are we going
there's something about being talked
through it and I and I think that's one
of the jobs of someone at the helm is to
build that narrative and part of that is
a creative endeavor right because you
don't necessarily know what to say but
you have to say something and I think
that's one of those maybe less discussed
muscles of a leader of a start-up is to
is to build that narrative and keep kind
of walking people through I mean one of
the things that I would oftentimes do is
play out best and worst-case scenarios
with with different dimensions so it you
mean play out for yourself or in front
of employees in front of the team what
would be an example of that yeah so I
mean a few things one is we had
a few different products we were kind of
pursuing a few different angles rather
and and I would oftentimes play out hey
this doesn't work maybe we use the
technology for this or if this business
model doesn't work we'll try that and
you know what if this doesn't work look
at what we will have learned over the
next three years I mean we are going to
be so marketable this is going to be one
of the best experience education any of
us has ever had and we're gonna be able
to get salaries at X instead of Y you
know and and that was also part of the
huh you know I would remember like
people feeling like a little more
comfortable when in fact the reality is
we were working and again complete
ambiguity and uncertainty and a little
lost well this this is I think having
observed some excellence great good
mediocre passable and not so good CEO of
over the last whatever it is 20 years
now Jesus I'm getting old anyway
this is I think one of the most under
discussed and valued sales functions of
the CEO right they think of selling
investors they think of selling
employees but for the hiring of those
employees yep
but to retain a team turns in the early
days this is so so important its
merchandising I mean think about the the
amount of capital that has spent on
billboards and advertising that compels
us to take action and do things every
day
it's obviously powerful yet why don't we
use those same mechanisms to get our
team to do things to get ourselves to do
things I think it's an important muscle
you're also trying to you're trying to
help your team accepted the burden of
uncertainty right and it's so much
easier when this stuff is around you so
you also use a dare I say I do dare
strange incentives for yourself and I
think I went as thumbing through some
things that you've said to me in the
past in terms of answers to questions
and so on I don't know if you still do
this but you have here like Scooby
Snacks and deep work rewards
you still do that I still do you tell
people just briefly what that is because
I'm sure a lot of people are listening
who are perhaps solopreneurs or
freelancers who might be for a lot of
the day by themselves so they have to
talk to themselves the way that you were
talking to employees yeah so what is
this what is if you could just describe
for people the well I mean it's I guess
it's short-circuiting my own reward so
story
I find the process of writing for
example pretty painful I have a writing
playlist that I only allow myself to
listen to if I'm writing and can you
listen to it from the get-go or do you
have to have to be in the zone and when
I find myself going to social media or
checking email whatever I make myself
stop it and I am NOT allowed to start it
again until I'm back in the writing zone
what are some of those those tracks do
you remember so there's a there's a
couple like great sort of melodies and I
kind of love I mean one is this piano
melody by a woman in Carly commando that
I discovered once there are gosh I mean
there are just a few other things that I
love that I think I can work with that I
don't want I didn't want to burn out but
I also you just wanted it to be like
that reward like when I'm back in the
writing zone I'm feeling it and is there
snacks and the snack so what is it what
are the snacks and when are you allowed
to have the snacks oh man
you know those these like really nice
kind of flaky buttery things that are
dipped in chocolate that they sell in
those what you called them yeah those
delicious yeah the chocolate flake bars
that I get from London whenever I'm
their only only something I can have
when I'm in the zone writing in this
case so in the zone now as a as a little
piglet myself I might be inclined to be
like oh man just now my first paragraph
let me have some chocolate so so what's
the bar for in the zone yeah no it's
it's when I when I get a material chunk
done when I feel like I I mean it was as
I talk about this it sounds ridiculous
but it's not right like how why don't we
take active more active roles and
governing ourselves and merchandising
and playing you know sales tactics with
ourselves with our teams you know just
like we do with customer
in the rest of the world and yes it
works for me
chocolate good music it will sometimes
that's enough to get me doing what I'm
supposed to be doing okay so we've
talked about reward systems are there
any other guidelines that you or
suggestions you would make to a founder
who finds himself in that very kind of
embryonic stage when they're realizing
wow okay I thought I in my mind had the
the excitement of a sprint but this is
not a sprint this is going to take some
time any other recommendations for
keeping a team motivated or examples
there's a lot of like tough moments in
that middle there are a lot of meetings
that don't have answers at the end
there's a lot of there's a lot of
periods again of that ambiguity where
you're kind of going in circles
there's rework you do want something you
realize that it was built on the wrong
tuck stack or that it was you know
totally tore the wrong type of customer
and you have to redo it again and and
leaving your team constantly with energy
even after those very difficult doubts I
remember you know one guy worked with a
guy named David Webb Hwanhee who's now
the CEO of AppDynamics company in
Silicon Valley but he I remember every
time I was in a meeting with him and
they could be like just the most
depressing meetings he would always kind
of end with a recap that would again
like spin it around towards we got this
if you've got the right people these are
the open questions this is the plan to
solve them in every would kind of end on
and up right and it's another one of
those tactics right to keep people
engaged enduring well one that we talked
about which isn't necessarily a reward
system but it reminds people why they're
doing what they're doing and why they've
made this gear shift into
entrepreneurship you gave me an example
earlier when we were hanging out that
was related to your I guess suppressed
memories during the five years of
bootstrapping when you went back to to
look at photos from that period to see
what was going on like wow I really
can't remember much from that period
what did you find
and that's something that comes up when
I talk to people like Derek Siver's or
others when they want to allow people
working on the products to see what well
um and it goes back to that reward thing
I think as well I went back in my phone
to that five years because I was
actually surprised by how much I had
forgotten yeah and I was wondering did I
forget it because I wanted to yeah was
there just nothing that is worth
remembering and and so yeah you know I
flicked back really quickly and my phone
back to those years and and what did I
find
I found tons of screenshots I found a
few thoughts I was always trying to find
like the flaws of our product and send
them to our team like this kind of never
feeling done since I also found a lot of
random screenshots of people saying nice
things about the product and then I
remembered gosh I used to always try and
a regular rhythm to send those around we
didn't have slack at the time but you
know you would post them on slack now I
guess those are again like those little
you know jolts of reward that are
keeping the team feeling it's you know
that this is it's the narrative but it's
it's it's doesn't it doesn't happen
naturally right and you have to you have
to look for it if the merchandize it
yeah I was surprised by how much of that
five years was just kind of this gosh
like you know late nights cuz you can
also see like the the time time stance
of screenshots it's like yeah I was
lying in bed at 2:00 a.m. typos around
but um but that was that is that is a
big part of it and once again you can
use this for yourself I mean I anybody
who is listen with this podcast long
enough or read any number of the last
few books that I've written knows that
I've had bouts with depression runs in
the family and I seem to have and I'm
working on it but a selective lens for
looking for searching for what is wrong
right and I think that at some point I
had it stuck in my head this was taught
this was definitely nurture not nature
not by my parents by by other
teachers and coaches that the good stuff
takes care of itself let me tell you
what you need to get better at right and
so I just developed this habit of always
looking for what is wrong and when you
do that it can it can put you or it can
put me at least into perhaps a
productive space but a funk that follows
that productivity at times and so I will
take screenshots of occasionally of
really meaningful say letters or
comments from fans and I will favorite
it on my on my phones that I have a few
things it's actually something I picked
up from comedian Whitney Cummings sort
of the the screen of zen-like
photographs of my dog photographs of
some of my best friends and my family
and then I'll have a a handful of these
to remember like oh yeah that's why I
like slog through the
neighborhood of the internet where half
the people are strong like potted plants
at your head out of the windows and deal
with all of the sacrifices is ultimately
for this like we're what we do touches
somebody else and it's it's so easy even
now for me to get kind of mired in
various details and that are an
important piece of the whole but you
kind of forget when the whole is put out
into the world what it can do doesn't
always do it but what it can do and
that's like the positive part that that
helps you keep going yeah I think
there's also though a the other
discipline belief that first of all you
just have to sometimes just do your
job right I think that was your
answer and travel mentors to what do you
do when you feel what was it scattered
or overwhelmed I whisper to myself Scott
do your job you know I do and
especially in moments where I've had to
make a difficult move fire somebody make
a difficult call have a difficult
meeting there is that sometimes whisper
you know of hey yes I could try to you
know find other ways to make me feel
good about this or I'm just gonna tell
myself that this is what it takes what
I've never asked someone because well in
many cases these are people I've
or spoken to before that I'm
interviewing but we spent a lot of time
together is there an emotion that you
returned to a lot that was disabling in
the five years when you were
bootstrapping or afterwards right like
some people have a default emotion that
crops up in certain periods of stress -
mine was for a long time I think I'm a
lot better now
anger mm-hmm some people it's like guilt
or depression or sadness or a feeling of
being hurt it could be any number of
things yeah for me it's probably two
things I think that it is the
realization that I'm not my best self
when things are going the best or when
things are going really badly when
things are going really really well I'm
not my best self because my ego can get
in the way and when things are going
really badly I'm not my best self
because my fear is getting in the way
and so when it comes to that question
around self-awareness I think that was
actually a big breakthrough at least
personally for me was like gosh it's
when things are going really well that
you start to say hey you know we don't
have to pay attention to competition
anymore taking our eye off the ball hey
we must have we must have actually you
know there's a false attribution problem
we must have done everything right so
we're gonna keep doing that stuff and
then again we're rewarding good outcome
without looking at process that hurts
and and that you know that can be a
fatal flaw and and when things are not
going well and it's suddenly fear
driving you then you can start paying
too much attention to competition and
start looking like them so is that
that's something you did at the time oh
yeah and then I think throughout the
throughout my journey do you did you
notice that because you were taking
notes on your own responses to things or
was it just a realization one day that
those were patterns well I think it's
probably a little bit of both I mean on
the fear for example there was a there
were the early days of Behance there was
another product out there called dribble
that was doing little 400 pixel
snapshots of people's work and by the
way that always looks better than the
full project because you can pick which
little 400 pixel by 400 snapshot you
take and get a nice little beautiful
drop shadow and that will always look
great
we were just sort of bewildered by this
it was like wow like it's taking off so
fast it's obviously like a real
differentiation from our product and the
fear of that made us suddenly shift our
shift I can hear the tea I'm sure
fortunately these mics are very
directional so we should be okay that is
that is water boiling folks if you hear
it that is water not my stomach but and
you know what we made a mistake we took
our eye off the ball we spent a few
major cycles of our business trying to
make our own version of this small
little snapshot thing and then we
realized that actually distracted from
the core part of the product that made
Behance good and it was again like bad
judgment out of fear and I didn't have
that self-awareness at the time to
realize that I was cueing our entire
product roadmap and convictions that the
team had out of my you know being at a
low point and that in that in that
example so I think that's one of those
examples where it was more in retrospect
I think at the time though I just try to
find I try to ask myself why I react to
things in certain ways why did that
meeting make me feel unsettled what was
it like this is something that someone
said is it and and if it was if I can
trace it back you know why does that
either make me afraid or make me feel
like you know I think you have to be
kind of propping those questions and if
you do with it once you have identified
a reason or in the what and you can
answer either of these but say you you
realize that you overreacted to
competition in the case of dribble and
ended up miss spending a lot of
resources as a result how do you ensure
that doesn't happen again or how did you
or you could you could talk because I
think they're so interrelated you come
out of meeting you're like why'd that
unsettle me okay well is it fear is it
something else is something else that
gets fear what is it fear of it's fear
of this right what do you then do with
that because I mean I think the the
hardest advice to take is often the
advice you have given yourself or
already yeah realize that you need to do
I mean not too
can't the mr. Derek Siver's again
although we've been talking about him so
all good things Derek but I think he is
the one who said in one of our
conversations that if more information
were the answer we'd all be billionaires
with six-pack ABS
we all have a very good idea of a lot of
things that need fixing or improving but
so what what then like you figure it out
and I'm asking selfishly cuz I've got
tons of stuff to work on what do you do
well I'm still figuring out as well but
yeah but I would say this is where the
team comes in I I have and I've always
had people on my team that were really
different and well let's I start to
interject this is this is really your
your Bramante it can be my scapegoat but
let's take the meeting example yeah you
don't have to identify any people but
let's get super granular like is is
there something there's not to be a
meaning that unsettled you like walk us
through what hypothetical are we all
kind of an example and then what you
would do after that like how that would
inform future behavior hmm well I think
let's see I'm thinking of a few recent
examples and one is when there's a
meeting I was in recently where I came
in with a number of priorities that I'm
focused on and which ultimately means I
want them resourced I want to invest in
these these are things I want to put my
chips on and and I felt pretty you know
committed and and felt like I did a lot
of diligence and then the the kind of
the question was how could you say that
all of these should be resourced how
could you not come in and you know
really just talk about one okay so that
was the response from the other side
that was a response to either side and
it threw me off I was like one you know
I've got lots of products and lots of
things going on and and and you know
every business is dynamic how could you
not have one thing I mean that sounds
crazy and it really threw me off and and
then I and then I started to think gosh
like maybe I am maybe I'm doing what I
always tell people not to you know maybe
I'm spreading myself too thin I'm not
you know having an
conviction on the one thing that matters
am i a good manager my good leader my
being formed properly do I have enough
data I am you know you started having
all those kind of self doubts arise and
and then I think I mean in this
particular situation I I did a few
things I mean one is I started to play
out some scenarios in my head I don't
know is there one thing that's
disproportionately likely to make an
impact more than everything else and
actually like I thought that got of the
list of 10 or so things like there were
probably a couple that I would say yeah
like if I had to pick one or two I think
that those have an outsize proportion or
likely to making an impact so why
wouldn't I just go all-in and and then I
started to realize well it's because I
have some doubts on those and I want to
hedge myself are you doing this in your
head in your office as a post-mortem are
you doing it on paper typing it out
usually I'm doing it on planes
III benefit from the disconnected period
where you're just kind of letting things
churn it definitely does not happen in a
meeting because in a meeting you're
defensive you feel like you have to have
a view you have to have an opinion it's
have an answer especially if you're a
leader but it's really outside right
when you're just disconnected and you're
kind of letting it run through your head
and if you have but what you have to be
doing is is starting from the belief
that you're wrong yeah
if you start from the belief that you're
right and everyone else is right what do
they mean you know these are my 10
things and I've already you know I know
that these are all important it's not
gonna get you anywhere right and you
well it sounds like you don't have to
necessarily believe that you're wrong
but you have to as an exercise a suit
what if you doing and it's it's
provocative because I mean and you have
to be provocative and you're thinking
right so you know I actually when you
when I when I when I caught myself on
the fact that it was actually sort of
about hedging then it's like well what
are my doubts about those one or two
things and maybe I should just spend a
cycle of my time on just those and and
that actually in this case impacted a
number of meetings I set up in
conversations I had and some data that I
requested and whatever and
remember after that whole process being
like okay like that was that was like a
good cycle leadership right there this
is a great example
I appreciate you playing along so on the
plane when the announcement comes over
the intercom and they say we're so sorry
and we're sorry you miss spent another
$12 the Wi-Fi is not working everyone
else is cursing and you're like sweet
I'm going to get so much self
development done are you doing this in
your head
same question on paper on a on a
computer offline how are you running
through this these these what-if
scenarios I usually start in my head and
and then I start getting a little
anxious because I'm like ooh you know
I'm actually this is something I need to
be this is going to cause a chain of
actions that I have to take in which
case I will then I have also in Evernote
action tracking lists where it's like
the things that if there's one thing I
want to look at every day that I'm sort
of tracking that require some action or
thinking through or whatever deep
churning and I immediately like kind of
added it to the list and then I think
that that's when it starts to become
more of a process unless of a
provocative inner inner inner monologue
awesome that was great uh let's let's
dig back in speaking of well I think
that one of those little notes that that
made it to the finish line for me was
was this question around suspending kind
of disbeliefs as another like tactic
towards endurance
I remember my father as an orthopedic
surgeon but when he was a resident he
was working one of those crazy New York
City hospitals where people come in with
like overdoses and shooting wounds and
stuff like that and he was telling me
that the most often kind of prescribed
so she had a cycle on the psychiatric
stuff that came in was I was like a
hundred CCS or whatever of obecalp which
is of course placebo spelled backwards
and and how like you know as soon as you
know someone be like obecalp stat you
know hundred CCS that would suddenly you
know that would switch something giving
a lot of these patients Minds in terms
of like where they felt they were in
their hope right yeah and you know
suck with me and I was always kind of
wondering that kind of how do I
prescribe that you know to myself and I
think there are many different tactics
there I mean one that I've heard from a
number of folks who have worked at
Google over the years and have been in
certain meetings with Larry Page where
he'll say great yeah good plan how do
you do a hundred xn and that jolt to the
system suddenly throws that the current
project plan out the door like all the
kind of near-term doubts you had don't
matter anymore it's like a hundred times
that like we have to be doing something
completely different
right and in some ways it's sort of the
same effect because first of all the
disbelieves you had in your in your more
reserved plan are suddenly out the door
because that sounds easy suddenly
because this new thing like I don't even
know where I'd start and and I think
that there's some that there there are
ways we can make sure that we just have
exponentially more like belief in
ourselves at times now part of it also
is is a is is also taking taking pride
in how naive you are in certain areas I
mean I remember talking to the our B&B
guys and a few other teams that talked
about how they didn't even know the
terminology of the industry they were
trying to compete in and how that
actually was a very empowering thing
because had they known that they would
have realized that some of their numbers
didn't match up early on and they would
have certainly abandoned you know the
project before it actually became a
business so I think that sometimes you
know hiring people that think
differently or don't have don't don't
have the traditional expertise that you
think you're needing to hire I think you
sometimes have to have to recognize the
benefits and not and not knowing too
much right the the constraints of an
industry which may already have been you
know obsolesce or expired and someone
who knows like any number of it's like I
really want another story of why we had
to wait until whatever it was 20 years
ago to have wheels on luggage right like
what
what was it what was the inertia or lack
of movement that made it take so long
it's incredible yeah I don't know the
answer but I don't either
uh what what other tools do you use when
you are talking to someone else because
they then could be telling themselves
perhaps something similar later as self
talk when you meet a founder who's just
getting crushed under the weight of
their own self-doubt and maybe they just
had to lay off half the company but
there it let's just assume for the time
being that there is product market fit
like the it is solving a problem but
they're just like I'm not a good CEO I'm
not a good fill-in-the-blank I don't
know if I can do it they're down what do
you say to people like that when they're
in those circumstances well I usually
start by reminding founders that one of
the greatest competitive advantages is
simply sticking together long enough to
figure it out and how they shouldn't
necessarily beat themselves up about the
the the daily volatility because it's
basically just a series of ups and downs
in which you hope you have a positive
slope at the end of the day and you hope
that every you know next low is a little
higher than the one before it right and
if you can just have a team stick
together long enough and and if you have
continued conviction in the end state
then it's really a matter it's a fight
against time and I really believe that I
mean some people might say oh no no you
can keep at it forever
a labor of love has a way of paying off
just not how you'd expect and and what
of course you do have to and when
founders feel really low and no
sometimes I'll say well but how do I
know whether I should quit or not well
that's one of the most common questions
that surfaces through the ether from
listeners and podcasts and readers of
mine is how do I know when to persist
because you always hear like you even
said yourself we had multiple near-death
experiences right right and if you're
bootstrapping
I got you know you you there's a
oftentimes the survivorship bias in say
media coverage where it's like oh
so-and-so took out like a 14th mortgage
and solace to his left kidney and now he
runs Alibaba you know whatever I mean
that's not a real story guys and making
that up but you you hear these
remarkable tales of throwing caution to
the wind but you you don't get to see
the bodies littered on on the side of
the street so a question that I get from
people who are trying to do the
responsible thing is how do I know when
to cut my losses and stop a project or
just put rip on a headstone for my
company and move on versus persist
through these very difficult times well
I think I mean to me the answer is
pretty simple first of all you recognize
the fact that everyone's kind of messy
Mittal journey is is is is at times
hopeless and and and that self-doubt is
a real thing and and so you're not alone
however if you start to lose conviction
in what initially set you off on this
journey I mean that's a serious thing
and however if you have as much if not
more conviction for the problem they're
trying to solve then you have to stick
with it and that's actually what I
typically will ask teams when they when
they're making having that question how
do you assess conviction um to me it
conviction is is really about knowing
that the world is going to be a certain
way based on all of the work and and and
research and experiences that you're
having and I don't care what the company
is what the product or service is it
you're trying to make as you go about it
day by day you learn more and and you
start to realize where you were right
and where you were wrong and and you're
always wrong a little bit I mean that's
the whole point about pursuing a product
market fit however a lot of teams will
will realize wait like people actually
don't need to do blah blah blah you know
they don't they don't want to have you
know laundry done within a three-hour
thing and that's not a real opportunity
but since we raised two million dollars
we've got a team working like we're just
gonna stick with it I actually think
they should quit however if the answer
is oh my god like this is even more
inevitable than we ever thought yeah
this is more important this problem is
actually going to be bigger than we
realized and you know we just have so
much more conviction even though she's
hitting the fan right now and gosh our
product is completely wrong right and we
have to start all over again that teen I
would say you guys have to stick with it
like you're just Yuri in that classic
kind of mode of whoever sticks with it
long enough is going to figure this out
so that to me is really where the
decision point comes down to have you
you know what rather than I was gonna
throw out a tough case but which you see
sometimes let's say like oh do way back
in the day although ultimately it
transmogrified in some fashion into
Twitter yep but they're pursuing what
one could argue has become the now
ubiquitous podcasting and things of that
sort but they paddle for the wave really
early right alright since I guess I
guess sometimes it's a case where the
not to throw some investing quotes in
here but I will send some well
caffeinated I don't know don't know the
attribution I really wish I did it might
be Templeton but the the markets can
remain irrational longer than you can
remain solvent right something like that
well timing is timings a first of
all and you know investing is really
less about is really less about the
future and it's more about the present
in what way in the sense that you can
have the greatest idea for ten years
from now but you know it's again like
time is the enemy of every bold endeavor
it's just like super hard to keep people
engaged long enough and keep of course
capital and everything else you need to
stay away stay alive long enough until
the planets align and the timing is
right and I think that and so that's why
I would say that so much of of investing
is really about just knowing exactly
what's right around the corner were
already there and and then and and
making your like product and team bets
based on that knowledge rather than ten
years in the future yeah something like
a lot of investors
get stuck because it's easy to be a
visionary ya know that someday yes we
will have flying cars that does not mean
that we need to be making flying parking
lots at this moment what else do you
have I mean one last thing on that
friend I would say is something I've
seen for a number of founders I know Ben
Silbermann co-founder of Pinterest is is
one one person who really like thinks
this way we were talking about that kind
of long you know long journey multi
years and and in the end and the
merchandising and whatever and this idea
of breaking it down into chapters he
when he talks about Pinterest he'll talk
about the fact that you know you're
after product market fit then there was
the year of internationalization and
everything in the company was geared
around let's let's let's go global let's
stop these clones and then there was a
year around monetization let's figure
out how are we gonna have a business
here you know and and each year has had
it has been like a chapter and that's
how he Alex Ames prioritization and and
and and maybe I guess kind of goes back
to that you know drive with a with with
with no side out the windows like how do
you keep the team engaged but it's um I
think it's I think it's crucial point
and it's part of part of the endurance
question you need you use the the
metaphor of the the key like kidnap car
with the blacked-out windows one that
I've also heard not applied to startups
but two novels actually writing novels
that I like quite a lot and I do not
remember the attribution on this either
but it definitely wasn't me which is
writing a novel is a bit like driving
across the country with your headlights
on yeah and Lamont very well could've
been in Lamar because bird by bird is
one of my abs you got favorite books and
I gift it to everybody which I should
probably also give to startup founders
quite frankly yeah I thought I mean a
lot of the lessons are the same but you
can get to your destination even though
you can only see 20 feet in front of you
right I think it's part of it you know
the other part of it about it is is how
you kind of build patience into the way
your team is built I mean if you look at
company like Amazon I think there is a
there there they kind of like have a
cultural set up for patience this notion
of being willing to be misunderstood for
a very long period of time it's very
embedded in the culture and and you hear
lots of ways that that's perpetuated and
then you take a company like Google
where I think actually they've tried to
also build patience in but not as much
cultural more structural so this notion
of alphabet and all these little
companies that are able to kind of exist
on their own as if they were in a VC
portfolio versus subject to the
quarterly cadence of a large public
company mm-hmm
so I think it's breaking those down into
chapters yes it's the what did Amazon
start interrupt but the the being
misunderstood for a long period of time
is that as a company or as a person
within the company well it's it's it's I
think it's both I mean obviously and
they do have their whatever it is not 10
commandments but like the 10 tenets of
Amazon or something up on Amazon
somewhere I don't I don't recall exactly
what they referred to as they also their
their original shareholder letter that
they attached to every you know new
shareholder letter and is sort of a
Bible within the company that also is
all about that it's basically saying
we're gonna do what's right for the
customer at the expense of a lot of
other near-term opportunities to
generate profit right and and that is
that becomes a cultural tenant that
obviously impacts the decisions that
leaders make across their businesses and
I think that's why something like AWS
became such a large part of their
business Amazon Web Services yes and and
you you see other parts of their
business become huge businesses on their
own because they're just willing to
invest that way you have to have a way
though because I think the the
realization here is that we are all
inpatient I mean part of my belief is
that it's it's just biological right I
don't know what our life expectancy was
hundreds and hundreds if not thousands
of years ago but it was held a lot short
and that it is today and so the notion
of committing 10 years of your life to
something was just insane and very
unwise right and so when we do that we
are get out there appropriate now we're
getting we're going
biological tendencies and so you have to
have hacks you have to have those short
term reward system hacks you have to
have you know things like the cultural
mechanisms or the structural mechanisms
that push patients the chapter is the
marriage merchandising since I'm going
with stream-of-consciousness for a
minute and certainly going off-script
you mentioned Amazon I'm fascinated by
Amazon strict Hickory this blog has some
fantastic fantastic articles on Amazon
and and one recently her not so recently
a few months ago on the acquisition of
Whole Foods and I thought was really
astute I was introduced it by devolver
avec on thanking of all what do you read
when it comes to investing
entrepreneurship or other like are there
any newsletters main Twitter accounts
anything that you can mention that you
find really thought-provoking well Ben
Thompson who you just mentioned surgery
is is certainly you know one of the one
of the greatest thinkers I think on
what's happening every day and always
has a unique spin and has a lot of
actually helpful self references because
they'll pull up things he wrote three
years ago not only to take a victory lap
but also actually it's a very like
helpful reference because it helps you
kind of understand how some of these
things could have been predicted and
what the strategy is behind a lot of
these moves I think they're yeah there
are a lot of different investors that I
am that I follow or subscribe the
newsletters for because I want to hear
it
you know their view and try think of
others who yeah in anyone who comes to
mind recognizing this is not an
exhaustive or a complete list but yeah
folks folks who you like trying to
Griffin a guy who has been at Microsoft
for a long time you know close to Bill
Gates and as could have observed the the
software industry evolved and has a lot
of insights around what's going on with
all the mayhem these days with
valuations and certain companies that
are exploding without concrete business
models and he kind of always kind of
boils it down to things like cost of
customer acquisition lifetime value of a
customer but
it's a it's just again like I like
people who come from a vantage point
with an extreme bias in his case towards
those fundamentals trying to make sense
of everything all you know everything
else it's crazy in the world that's
helpful in Wren Griffin his name is
trend Griffin right Josh wolf who's a
great investor in New York of a firm
called Lux capital he's actually been an
extreme skeptic of Tesla for a very long
time you know calling out from his
vantage point around some of the
fundamentals and also I think he's used
to entrepreneurs that have very kind of
wild personalities for future narratives
and he pokes holes for a living in that
and so he has some perspective on on
what he thinks you know may be happening
on the Tesla front which is always
interesting so he's another example of
someone who just kind of you know
grounds what you're reading on the
headlines with some some different
perspective fanatically if you look at
the non investment reading that you do
mm-hmm
if you look at the pie chart was there
is there anything in particular that
you're consuming a good amount of these
days or over the last say a year or two
you know I think that there's some some
biographies the Doris Kearns Goodwin you
know type stuff
the a few of the Walter I exists in like
classic biographies I think there's
recently read Shackleton's endurance you
know story appropriate yes which you
know obviously relates to my thinking
these days which is just a phenomenal
story and there's so many interesting
leadership lessons of counterintuitive
things that he did that helped you
understand you know difficult decisions
that have to be made and does anything
come to mind oh gosh asking I'm asking a
lot I know yeah I know but one actually
thing that stuck with me was was I
forget like the exact scenario but the
crew had a choice of going back and
getting all this food from the ship that
was sinking and everyone was like we
have to of course we have to get it of
court you know and we might be out here
for years we need as many supplies as
possible and but he didn't let them and
it was a
what do you mean you're the leader how
could you put your team at risk but he
realized that by by allowing not to
happen he would be sending its message
to his team that yes we will in fact
maybe be stuck out here for years and he
knew that that would be almost like a
death sentence to morale and to
everything else and so he just kind of
artificially constrained their lifeline
to some extent to make sure that the
team knew that we just had to win we had
to survive we had to move faster that's
an example
Wow that's the what are the what are the
constraints that you should inflict on
your team to make sure that performance
is at a certain level Wow
you have to be thinking quite quite
quickly to play through the different
scenarios in your head and make that
judgment call and be willing to be
unpopular yes and and you know and take
a risk I mean that's that's a risk right
so I think we we can maybe look at one
of the other legs of the of the stool
right we've put four three buckets what
what would be one example and I'm
thinking actually this would be a good
place to pause put on our most
fashionable swimwear and move into the
truth barrel if you're open to that I'm
ready okay pause
so here we are in my whiny sauna with a
submarine light you guys can look it up
very old-timey looks like perhaps even a
torture device in Rambo attached to a
the coils of a mattress of some time but
we are sitting in a barrel sauna the
specs of which were given to me by Rick
Rubin thank you Rick this is the second
time out of whatever it is 360 plus
episodes that I have attempted to do
podcast in a sauna so thanks for being
part of this experiment proud to be the
second and the acoustic might be a
little weird so bear with me dear
listeners and I thought I would I would
segue by selfishly focusing on my self
and a problem challenge that I ran into
a mere 30 minutes before you got to my
house because we were talking in the
indoor section about at one point the
importance of post-mortems and asking
yourself why you responded the way you
did to certain things and how you do
that work on plans and it is led to
insights and behavioral change you seem
to be and this will foreshadow maybe the
emotion that that I suffered from and
still suffer from right now as we sit
here having this conversation you strike
me as a very even-keeled guy I don't
think I've ever seen you angry not that
I've done anything to anger you I don't
think but my default in many situations
for reasons now known some I'm sure
unknown has been anger and it's been a
very valuable tool it's been a very
useful fuel in some instances mm-hmm for
endurance even to get things done but I
think that in many many circumstances it
is misplaced and outlived its usefulness
and it's just corrosive for me so here's
what happened for the last
few months I have been interacting with
this nonprofit to do volunteer work for
them and both to serve and to help but
also to learn a lot on the job so to
speak volunteering for them
turns out volunteering for them is
pretty popular quite a few people want
to volunteer so it's not perhaps as
straightforward as you might think
and I invested a lot of time in emailing
back and forth with these folks for what
I would consider an extended period of
time and I sort of in the back of my
mind well we'll get to that but think I
think about opportunity cost quite a lot
as it relates to time time in particular
this this non-renewable resource that we
have so put a ton of time in which I
hoped would end up in some type of
solution for both sides that would allow
me to get a bunch of valuable experience
so we agreed to a certain format like
let's just call it four sessions three
or four sessions of volunteering in a
very particular capacity and set in
motion all these plans I said are we
confirmed because I'm going to be
expending a lot of money and planning
and logistics like 20 grants something
like that to actually get to you to do
this properly and they're like yes
absolutely no problem all right so I
received finally after tons of tons of
back and forth the schedule for my
volunteering on none of the days we
discussed the capacities that I do not
match up with what we had planned and
I've already sort of irrevocably spent
this money yep and I'm just like what
the and right and and so I was just
trying to kind of talk myself into some
level of was something resembling calm
before you got here it was like you know
what I can't let this ruin my whole
night that's ridiculous and infantile so
let me throw on some music we have some
tea let me play with the dog let me do a
B and C which worked like I'm it I'm
enjoying hanging out and it's not
possessing me like a demon but I do fear
because this is my pattern
as soon as you leave now for the weekend
right I'll confess sir yeah I'm gonna be
thinking about this which will not have
any resolution yeah if it's if it's
going to have any resolution which you
might not it's not gonna happen until
next week Monday onward right so what
would you do in this in this
circumstance or if you were in my shoes
as my mink yourself if your even-keeled
self were right right or what would you
how would you think about this in my
shoes yeah well listen work on it like
that this end and just for people
listening I wanted to take us in this
direction just for the the first portion
of this part do and the sana because
this is in fact the type of thing I
would ask you about yeah you're a friend
and I get asked all the time like if
okay we've heard that you're the average
of the five people you associate with
most who do you associate with most and
why
and and you would be an example I would
be like I aspire to develop these
characteristics which I think are
exemplified in Scott that I've not yet
developed and so you are even killed I
think by normal standards I'm pretty
even-keeled but like I can turn into the
Hulk also and that is something that I
would come to you yeah with and so Scott
you seem to know something I don't know
or have developed something I have
developed what would you do if you would
have given me the story you just gave me
in a sauna late one evening and I was
trying to give you advice yes what I say
I think that first of all I always ask
myself when I'm angry about something
which I do get on occasion is this in my
influence or out of my influence like is
this something that I can directly end
or shift or is this just like the
universe is against me at this moment
and I'm just gonna have to like roll
with it and how much of my energy am I
going to give to it if I have no
influence over it mm-hm and because then
it kind of
in math for me it's like all right like
this sucks but you this the sunk cost
thing kind of flaw is oftentimes you
know the the the the wild-card in this
notion of righteousness that a lot of us
have I think yeah and if it helps it all
I would say that when something is
obviously outside of my control yeah a
crisis situation yeah a death in the
family a car accident something like
that I don't get upset or I can grieve
in the case of a death but yeah I can I
can handle it very very well
yeah sunk cost fallacy as it relates to
money yeah doesn't really apply uh-huh
for me at least like if I if I make a
bad bet I'm not gonna follow up good
money after bad if it's not working out
but with time yes yeah different story I
think the other factor I do get that
righteous indignation which I recognized
almost always yeah
is a huge miss expenditure of additional
energy and time listen I mean I'm with
you and I think I feel this a lot often
times when I am stuck in a phone tree
you know you know it's just like this is
so expensive for for me in the sense of
how I value my time like gosh you know
it's frustrating and I mean the other
question is that I often times ask
myself when I have anger towards someone
or something is um is how much can I
expect people to be changed mmm well
that's a good that's a great one
particular people in particular
industries companies nonprofits at a
certain stage with a certain caliber of
talent with whatever else like what can
I expect and and what's reasonable and
what's not because listen I think
there's a part of us
that believes that everyone can and
should change and so if there's an
in-law or a parent or whatever in it
they just are always aggravating us it's
like shame on them and they should
change and that can actually be where
the anger comes out and that whole kind
of notion of teaching old dogs new
tricks
I do say that to myself quite often I'm
like a like
is this person really gonna change as a
leader of a team - there's only so much
you can develop people into and at some
point there's just certain limitations
that I think people have and then I feel
like I'm getting too pragmatic here and
of course I believe in the potential of
people and I believe in change but when
it comes to managing anger I think it's
also like hey you know what is in my
influence what is out how much can I
expect this person org industry whatever
to change and and you know and then and
and then use and then you have to become
like a fierce protector of like
extraneous energy how do you then in a
case like this where I I do actually
want to volunteer ideally in the
original capacity that yeah we at least
in my view agreed to
how would you then explore resolution or
next steps in your own head well the
hack that I would use yeah is that what
I'm enduring in this case and putting up
with what I'm tolerating is part of my
contribution so when I when I go to
nonprofit and board meetings and that
sort of thing that I find generally
speaking much less productive than a
than other organizations I'm involved in
or certainly startups or it's all about
you know what needs to get done let's
get out of here let's do everything so
scrum and it's a standing meeting it's
obviously very different
I do sometimes tell myself like this is
this is part of the condition that I
committed myself to work under I'm
reminded of a great piece of advice that
John Maeda one of my mentors once gave
me I think I shared of you maybe could
you to just for people who don't know
him who is who is that John is is is it
just a brilliant designer and thinker he
was the president of Rhode Island School
of Design before that he was head of MIT
Media Lab he spans both Technology
design he also wrote a book about
simplicity but in my life he's like my
personal Yoda the stuff that he tells me
has to kind of roll around in my head a
little bit to reveal its truth but then
it always kind of hits me and in this
case I was at my first ever board
meeting for the cooper-hewitt National
Design Museum a Smithsonian Institution
with you know people with famous names
on the board and and and a very kind of
old institution right and it just moves
slowly in some ways because that's how
it has sustained for so long of course
it hasn't gone through radical change
that's what makes it in some ways
sustainable and and I walked out of this
meeting and I said to John at the time
he was still president at around school
design I said gosh like how do you how
do you kind of manage such an
unproductive meeting like I think we
heard a lot of people speak we
celebrated certain people for doing
things I don't think we got anything
really done I don't know what is
actionable and he looks at me kind of
shaking his head being like oh you know
young Skywalker he sort of looked at me
and said you know Scott all these cool
startups and things that you're so
excited about doing and building and
founding they won't be around in a
hundred years but this will and it has
been and sometimes in life you find
something where all you can do is add a
brick and and that is an incredible
impact to something that will be around
forever and what I heard him saying in
that is that adding a brick in a
start-up is pathetic nothing I won't get
you anywhere alright so in some ways you
have to change your expectations and
have a greater tolerance for a you know
a different level of in some ways
performance or impact and I think what
you're describing is like this extra
debt you didn't you or add extra cost
rather you didn't think you were signing
up for that is one way at least for me
that I would excuse and be able to
manage it okay so that that gives me a
cooler head even in this hot for even in
the hot sauna without my wool hat buying
a professional Russian style we'll cover
that another episode especially
important if it bald heads by the way
but another time so now I have a cooler
head you know for the email or phone
call
how do you think about that is the
question how do you now keep a cooler
head well I mean the options to me I'm
sure are many but the ones that come to
mind are I can accept what they've yeah
suggested which is in no way
representative of what I that wouldn't
be what a person I know
yeah would not be me agreed to or
particularly want to do yeah and it
actually has some conflicts so it's it's
not really an option to accept it's
practical yeah number two is to ask for
something completely different which is
in fact what we agreed to in the
beginning but they've already slotted
all the other volunteers so may or may
not be possible yep
or something in the middle or or I don't
do it at all right the Tim that I would
know by default in my opinion knowing
you know haven't you only four years is
uh you'd say I'm out right you guys
didn't this is how we agreed on time
above all else I want to be with high
performers work with things that are on
point this is just going south yep that
is my instinct yeah but I really there's
the other part of me that's like maybe
you just need to wait for your
testosterone to decrease over time it's
good and you should try a different
approach because there are times when I
have cut off my nose - despite my face
yes you know out of principle would be a
justification and in retrospect it's
just like what the really
I mean I mean I'm all for principles but
principles tend to ignore nuances and
other practicalities and again like the
limitations of some people and
organizations and constructs and
industries and situations
hmm maybe the exercise is to go back and
say hey like this is now we agreed on
and you know and you know this this is
what will work for me you know can we
can we still make this work for me and
give them like one more you know
chance slash all the branches and see
where it goes but I also on the
counterpoint believe that this sort of
thing tends to be a repeatable pattern
and you probably know what you're in for
yeah we'll see I mean maybe you know
this surprised me so maybe their
response to the next one will equally
surprise me but hey this post-mortem
like this
process I mean this is what develops
muscle memory this is what develops our
you know our judgment and honestly I
even though there's no clear resolution
I feel better about it just having
walked through the kind of practical
tactical yeah next steps so I don't have
to
hopefully pace around kind of shaking my
fist at the sky for the weekend which
ready absolutely wasteful right because
even if I have the time this weekend if
I have no attention because I'm fixated
on this and get separating that's a
waste and listen yeah I mean I think
it's a Holy Grail type of thing that
this notion of can we compartmentalize
our uncertainty our fear our anger in
situations and somehow be able to allow
the other 90% of our brain to optimum to
operate as if it weren't there I mean
that's the gold standard and I remember
being on my honeymoon two years into the
start of my startup and thinking gosh
like how we were responsible am I like
I'm here in Thailand and my team is back
grudging through it and we're this many
months out of not making payroll and
whatever else and you know yes there was
a part of me that was like but this is
your freaking honeymoon and like you get
this one soap fully and and you got to
like at least be present for part of it
and I remember that was like the
beginning of my education and trying to
cart mentalize that stuff it's
hard do you think that is a do you think
that is a word in retrospect having had
all your experiences since then has it
worked well for you I mean what do you
recommend it
and I mean yeah and what does that
really mean on you know I think it's I
think it's on a cognitive level or not
necessarily Meccan you know
mechanistically but right for someone
who says wow bielski sounds like a super
chill at peace guy there's this
compartmentalizing thing that he first
saw the light on on his honeymoon i
should try that what do they try sure
yeah I think it's well my attitude is
that I actually admire people on both
ends of the spectrum here and I have
less admiration for those in the middle
probably myself on one side of the
spectrum you have those true pros that
are able to just have all this going on
I remember that story about Barack Obama
right as they were captured
or killing a you know Osama bin Laden
and he was like at an event that night
you know cracking jokes and whatever
knowing this was going on in the back
and you look at that you're like that
guy must be a bro yeah how do I do that
and then and then the other end of the
spectrum I admire people that are just
like truly with their emotions and
authentic and they're like these were
the dates we agreed on
sorry deal off like don't call me again
like there's actually something about
that that I admire from like a truth and
emotionally connected governed way of
living it's in the middle where you're
kind of and I'm actually wondering now
if it's sort of like the blackjack rule
you either always hit on sixteen or you
always stay on sixteen but like don't do
it based on your list right don't it be
inconsistent yeah I definitely aspire to
be more on the pro side and that kind of
goes back to the do your job
thing I tell myself in my head sometimes
when I am feeling like I am going to
sleep with this compartmentalize
uncertainty or fear or anger or whatever
and it's just okay if you're a pro like
you should be able to do this yeah yeah
that's kind of what I tell myself
yeah well it's a it also reminds me and
by that I mean your comment related to
this as part of your contribution is
like the suffering through might be too
melodramatic but tolerating things that
move more slowly things are a little
more disorganized that's part of your
contribution with group acts or person
why and it it makes me think of
something that I haven't thought of in a
while that Robert Rodriguez the
filmmaker said when I was chatting with
him on the podcast and that was yes film
like I'm paraphrasing here of course a
Robert forgive me if I get it somewhat
off but the filmmakers come up to him
all the time they're like yeah I was
working on my film and I was doing this
but you know this went wrong and like
the lights blew out and then we hadn't
rented XYZ for the right period of time
even though I told them that we were
supposed to do it and then this and this
and this and they they list off this
litany of complaints and however it just
says or he said to me you know they
don't realize like that is the job like
if you sign up to be a filmmaker your
job is that nothing is gonna go right
and
is what I do right and it's it's almost
like when you build a not to bring
everything back to product management
but when you build a plan you either add
one point you multiply it by 1.1 1.2 1.3
based on what the team is how part the
product is how many unknowns there are
and that is your timeline and I would
argue that when you work with certain
types of organizations or you undertake
certain commitments you have to multiply
it by a 1.2 but you're gonna have a few
misunderstandings and back and forth and
one date change and if you actually went
into this knowing that that was the
status quo he wouldn't be known as upset
yeah absolutely absolutely right all
right so let's talk about the the second
bucket optimize and now do we need it
through the first and I have to say like
endurance is not sexy but it's just we
have to know we're not alone these are
important to think about definitely so
now that we're half naked and sitting in
a sauce wedding together let's get sexy
yeah where would you like to start we
would like to start I mean for me all
these you know the ADIZ insights that I
kind of catalog into the optimization
side you know fell in these camps of
team self product and and how would you
start you know on some of the team stuff
and this could be like whether you're
just getting a few people to work with
you you're starting something as a solo
entrepreneur or you're actually leading
a team you know I think one you know I
would just start with the fact that um
that we all know you know how important
it is to be resourceful and and not just
rely on more and more resources to solve
problems I think it's pretty common
knowledge that if you're constrained
it's this form of creativity and there's
a million stories about that I like to
think about especially in the startup
world resources are like carbs
resourcefulness is like muscle it's just
when you develop it it actually stays
with you and impacts like everything you
do going forward I think when you're
bootstrap for a period of time and force
to develop that muscle that serves you
forever and of course the stories of
people raising way too much out of the
gate and never developing that muscle
typically actually don't end quite well
so when it comes to you know thinking
about that you know couple thoughts we
and you know one story is
when I first hired our first kind of
Operations leader a guy named Will Allen
from actually he worked at TED
conferences prior to that and he came on
board too
to kind of kick some operational prowess
into how we were working as a company
and I remember every time teams would go
to him saying hey we're growing we gotta
you know we need a bigger budget for web
storage space we need more people for
this for that function in whatever we
would always say it has had this mantra
refactor refactor than hire and it was
and he just believed fundamentally that
every team can go through one or two
refactoring cycles what do you mean by
that
and what that means is first of all if
it's a human heads perspective it's like
well like each person oversees one part
of the product could they oversee -
instead are there any benefits to that
should we cut some of the craft like are
there people that we should shift around
should we actually pick the feature that
people are using the least and just kill
it and take those resources and put it
on this new thing I mean those
conversations inherently don't happen
when you have resources at your disposal
you don't they have to happen and when
they are when you have to choose between
the two it has to be forced I guess is
my point
mm-hmm and and that has become like a
real actual principle for me as a
manager and as a board member and as an
advisor is constantly challenging teams
so like find creative ways they can
refactor and also making the case even
if they have the resources as to why
that benefits them you know I was I was
just going to say that one of the most
valuable things that I've done in the
last few years which I should have
started a lot earlier that I'm I think
I'm I'm better at than perhaps the
avoidance of emotional reactivity is
relates to anger certainly is journaling
on hypothetical questions that constrain
your resources even if you have them
interesting so you have a year for say a
given project a book a competition a
campaign all right we have it scheduled
for whatever it might be right a year
three months what if we had to
accomplish what if we had to finish this
and it might mean that the metrics
change in one week yes right what if we
had to finish this
we couldn't personally as a team touch
it you had to outsource all of it would
that simplify the specs
would that simplify what you submit all
right and then does that end up being
usable by the team right and I apply it
to time any currency I can think of
right headcount if one person had to do
this how would the description of the
project need to change if we had to do
it with X amount of dollars which is
1/10 what we're budgeting yeah
absolutely had to and write down how
that would change the implementation
without fail has made every project I've
applied that to dramatically better by
the way
I mean it's true on the individual level
a small team level there's also a
company a company called skybox
that was started by four Stanford
students they they decided that their
goal was to build a satellite with
off-the-shelf parts at a time when
satellites cost hundreds of millions of
dollars and they were look they were
like off-the-shelf parts that is the
ultimate constraint and that was the
fuel of innovation they ended up
building satellites between two to five
million which is a fraction right of
what satellites were being built for and
at this and then like a year or two
later Google acquired them because of
their innovation in the space of you
know economically and resourcefully
building something that was otherwise
out of touch yeah that's a great story
yeah uh that for people you want to want
to hear or read a great story of
resourcefulness this just reminded me
and somebody else is gonna have to look
this up but there was a robotics
competition you might have have heard of
this or seen it a feature film was made
out of the story and I will put it in
the show notes guys but that a feature
film was made depicting this telling the
story of these low-income at-risk youth
who were encouraged to join a robotics
team one assay was in Los Angeles
mm-hmm by this incredible professor and
they I don't want to spoil the story but
the the narrative and the journey is
really the payoff not the the end which
is easy enough to figure out yep but
they were competing against these very
well-heeled
through upper-class perfectly educated
teams and they had to scrap by with
essentially no budget yeah to learn and
build robotics to compete underwater and
it's just such an amazing story and I
also remembered Jack mom know Alibaba at
one point and I'm gonna make it the
order slightly wrong but he said we had
a number of advantages when we began we
had no strategy no money no experience
right and it's a common story yeah and
it's um it is counter-intuitive and even
if you benefit from that you actually
still start to operate differently when
you start having the resources your
disposal the same thing by the way goes
for hiring you know another thing that
you know I've observed in many instances
is initiative being more important than
experience yeah and you're hiring people
and you could be it when you have the
resources you tend to become a resume
snob and you're like oh well I'm gonna
have the VP of this from Google or
whatever but when you don't have the
resources you actually have to hire for
something else because you can't afford
to hire those people and so you heart
start to measure people base on well are
they the type of person that takes
initiative on anything they're working
on like what's their history of doing
that and will they continue to do that
here
what is initiative mean in this case I
have an image in my mind because that's
something I look for to me initiative
it's it's really it's when you're
genuinely interested in something do you
take relentless persistent and
continuous action is it something that
you study hold your eyes up at night to
do more of versus are you are you
confining yourself to the job
description
yeah so in some of it some of I always
like to say like I feel like so much of
the futures is done by people doing work
they didn't have to do yeah and if
that's true it's really about people who
take initiative over like what they
believe their job is which theoretically
comes from having a lot of experience
you start to become a little bit more
confined cuz hey you've been down this
road before you've seen a 10times like
let me do my thing and by the way I have
three assistants at Google so are you
gonna help yeah for me I have a raincoat
in a while but yeah yeah but the you
know what jumps out to me and I I've
hired far fewer people than you have but
looking for deep examination of the
tasks they're given has proven really
valuable if I find if I which displays a
lot of qualities at once so if I give
them something really quickly because
I'm in a rush yeah but it's important
and I say all right off the cuff I
imagine we're gonna do a B and C and
then as as the final step you're gonna
have to choose between one two three
yeah and if someone comes back and says
I looked into all of that but I think
the better option is number four and I
actually tested this out yes and
although you didn't ask me to do this
you know on my own time I did this it's
like okay that's initiative that
displays initiative it also displays an
understanding for the circumstances I
was experiencing buried under suffering
from when I gave the order yes they're
always asking is this what is the
outcome and is this actually the best
route to that outcome and by observing
that in other people I've become better
at it myself yes which is which has been
a huge key learning for me and this is
this is meandering quite a bit but that
is that is my way he says something that
also I mean you you vibes by observing
other people you can improve those
qualities in yourself you really pay
attention yes you're reviewing what
they've done and vice versa right you
have to be lead by examples hopefully
you're doing the same thing and you know
similarly when we're talking about anger
and these other emotions I realized that
when I'm having difficulty with a
particular emotion myself if I can step
out of my inward focus the mimimi focus
and try to help someone else with a
challenging emotion
ideally a similar emotion it gives me
the observer status the objectivity to
help them and they're like huh never
would have come up with that yes if I
were thinking about my own problem
because I'd be too wrapped up what's the
Carl Jung code you know that
understanding the darkness and others is
or understanding the darkness in you and
others it's like transferrable right
like all these insights we get yeah and
and I think the other piece here is just
that don't measure and
should have based on like stuff within
the field you're hiring the person for
like recognize that initiative is
transferable that past initiative is the
best indicator of future initiative and
be a little liberal with like you know
how directly applied it is I mean a
couple of the things on it on the on the
assembling the crew front that I was
kind of struck by that kind of made it
to the cut at the end of these insights
you know one of them is hiring people
who endured some form of adversity and
another one is hiring people with whom
every conversation you have with them is
a step function more interesting the one
before it on the university front you
know super quickly
Tristan Walker who's an entrepreneur you
started Walker brands and and and has
built the real business yeah he talks
about how he he grew up he had a tough
upbringing and he feels like one of the
things that he really carried from his
upbringing was courage and he feels like
he wanted to make that a true value of
their company and they asked him like
why is that sounds nice but why does
that really mean and he said only with
courage can you practice the same values
consistently so true yes yeah it's like
at the meta prereq sure because
otherwise you're always making
exceptions or always deviating but if
you have courage you will take on and be
consistent and so I was like well then
how do you hire for that and he was like
hey I look for people who went through
like I did and and it was
interesting you know that that lens into
why adversity actually is important when
it comes to building like a great
culture and actually a product and brand
and everything that's consistent the
other the other you know one brings you
back to the story of working with the
periscope team so this is a team that
was building a live streaming
application back in the day when
actually there was snapchat and other
products that were more about facials
and whatever but yeah that's photographs
we're in the Sun um yes
selfies selfies yes it's the heat I'm
told it's hot so it's so hot well
thermometer has been broken for the last
and this mic I can barely handle anymore
anyways but it you know it's so when I
met with that team and they were doing
something's kind of different they were
saying hey even though every real-time
video thing is more about selfies and
showing what you're doing to other
like we believe it's actually about
seeing the world through someone else's
eyes they had a lot of things like that
but what really drew me to them was
every kind I had a conversation with Kay
bond and his co-founder Joe it was
always like a step function more
interesting the one before it
and I remember juxtaposing not with most
conversations I have that our sort of
replays by step functioning me dramatic
improvement and this dramatic
improvement difference and every
conversation being like whoa new level
new plane new plane new plane and and
then now having gone through that
investment from the whole period of seed
through product promote good fit through
acquisition by Twitter I think one of my
one of my beliefs is that it was that
chemistry with them that actually kept
me engaged and also kept their team
engaged with them like it was just one
of those traits again that I actually
try to look for so I actually try to
meet candidates for senior roles twice
and I try to do a delta comparison
between the first conversation in the
second and oftentimes it's the same you
know like why am I here again I answered
these already yes and sometimes the
additional digging but sometimes just
goes in a completely new direction and
you're like you know what everyone who
works in this person it's gonna want to
keep working with them and so why hmm
so in the interest of keeping you
working with me as a friend I think we
will take a cool-off break and we will
be back pool
and here we are back in the wining
cylinder in the truth barrel and I
thought we might chat about now that
we've lowered our core temperature just
a wee bit a wee bit a wee bit uh uh
since we've been I think incorporating a
discussion of self in the discussion of
team quite a bit that we may be segue
into some self specific points meaning a
point or two and then what a lot of
people would love to hear about because
you're so known for it I think is
product and then we can move from there
see where the wind takes us yeah yeah I
mean on the on the yes you have to
optimize how your team works and there's
you know process improvements and blah
blah blah
there's also though the harder challenge
in a bold you know venture journey of
optimizing the way you work and think
and react and everything else we've
talked about a little bit I think um you
know one and one um you know one of the
you know little little insights that I
thought up quite a bit about was the
fact that you're you're true blind spot
is is how you appear to others and I
think that you know part of that is is
is understanding you know that we you
know we react obviously for all
different sorts of reasons to things you
know we react based on our the
confidence we have from the financial
security we may or may not have we react
based on all sorts of other factors when
it comes to just an altercation at work
or a decision that we make or whatever
else and knowing that then of course
everyone else you know interprets us as
we as sometimes irrational to their
contexts of where they're reacting from
and what their background is and
whatever else and this is about
surfacing what some of those what what
are the things that we're doing that we
don't even realize that other people see
and and scratch their heads kind of
thinking about um I remember this this
experience I had in high school where I
lived on a farm in Vermont for six
months one of those programs you apply
to and it was forty five kids on a farm
self-sustaining and it was a
real like it was more about community
than the farm frankly learning how to
coexist within a small group and govern
yourselves and that sort of thing like
Lord of the Flies junior year of high
school were you piggy and super thin but
yes but I but in one of the men of the
intense most intense exercises that we
did towards the end that I will never
forget is this thing called the mirror
exercise where you pair it up with
somebody and they would tell you what
they saw of course
from their experience having lived with
you 24/7 in a farm in Vermont and you
know that wasn't a physical thing it was
like what I see you afraid or I see
you're supposed to use verbs you know I
see you sometimes wondering you know if
you if you are in the right place or if
you have the right to speak or you know
they were just all these different and I
remember it hit me like a ton of bricks
I actually wish I remembered exactly
what the feedback was that I got what I
would think it was was that I had a lot
of insecurities and to pause just so I
understand the format did you have one
person who would give you five examples
was it a line and you had one person or
each person give you one item what did
it look like yeah so it was you paired
up with a few different people and you
had 10 minutes and you're doing it for
each other and the challenge was to not
it's it wasn't out of judgment it was
more like you were supposed to see what
you were just kind of you were supposed
to share what you were seeing without
really imposing so much judgment around
it which is hard because something sound
judgy but but it was it was you know I
think it was a it was a heartfelt
exercise and what it what it did is it
what I do remember keep taking out of it
was gosh people see things that I don't
I didn't realize I either showed or knew
you or didn't even know about myself and
and so you know from that I started to
in my professional experiences and in my
personal experiences I would often ask
the question of people I'm with like if
if you know if you were me what would
you do you know I would try to kind of
get someone else's take on a situation
from a
different set of again those things that
are the context of our decisions the
background struggles the issues with
your parents all the other stuff like
assuming everyone has a different thing
if you ask that question other people
and you see a Delta between your
reaction or your thought in theirs then
you actually at least know there's
something to explore there it's almost
like a canary and in the fact that okay
hey there's some projection going on
here there's there's some blind spot
that I am NOT fully aware of that is
interesting right yeah you're looking in
the mirror but like you said I mean the
blind spot very literally like a car or
there's just this empty pocket that you
cannot see and then the question is like
how do you fish it out like it's super
hard because it's literally not in your
mirror so have well a few questions
related to that first to the exercise is
there anything and it's a long time ago
I realized that the counselors or
leaders of the group said to everyone so
that they would receive yes without
becoming defensive actually which we did
the natural response for a lot of people
good myself probably yeah it's a good
question and I think that it reminds me
of like one part of it that I emitted
which was that we were also instructed
to really only at the end of the day
think about the ones we heard more than
once hmm so could you pass me your water
now that I've extinguished mine yes and
I will selfishly put my self
preservation ahead of yours
please condemn me I go through hard work
and then in your Casa but you know I
think that um that was it was somewhat
on because you know what you know what
that direction did first of all it made
people realize that if I tell someone
this because I'm judging them and they
don't hear it from others like I'm gonna
look like an idiot
so it had a preventative measure in that
sense it also helped the recipients
discount anything that they heard once
maybe it's psychologically still hard to
do it very helpful but it's a very
interesting trick have you ever done a
experienced a 360 interview uh-huh okay
so I did four reviews you mean right yes
360 yes sorry yeah a sixty review and
now it's my turn yeah turn my brain into
scrambled eggs and for those people who
don't know this is something a number of
my friends of experience which I didn't
realize until I did it myself
and felt like a broken human
being and was hit so hard that I wanted
to confess that to close friends and
they're like oh my god
yeah man you're telling me and I don't
want to mention names we've been very
people you would view is maybe not
immune to criticism but certainly these
like stalwarts of strength these like
monolithic pillars of resilience and
what a 360 review entails for people
wondering it's something I would
recommend to everyone actually and
they're there ways that you can do it
outside of a business context but what
it generally entails is someone wants to
figure out these blind spots
yeah figure out how they're being viewed
figure out what their better behaviors
are what their lesser behaviors are etc
and you will select with the person
who'll be doing the interviews it's not
you mm-hmm say peers people you report
to people who report to you yeah and so
on and so forth maybe suppliers
distributors who knows people you
interact with a fair amount and it's it
can be very sophisticated process you
can do this I actually did a very early
version of this it was really truncated
in high school because I read a book
called mental toughness training for
Swartz by Jim lair
Loa HR who's in the last two years
become friend which is crazy and awesome
really fantastic guy works with a lot of
athletes but it has an inventory that
you're supposed to give to coaches peers
teammates people who know you really
well and it would it made a huge
difference in my success as a wrestler
it was really a remarkable just to see
from like the day of receiving answers
which I received myself yeah up to next
day it was really astonishing how much
things change and with the 360 interview
though yeah just to come back to this
only pay attention if it comes up more
than once it's a very hard exercise even
if you prepare yourself at least in my
experience and experience of some of my
friends to take because you're seeing
these ugly truths especially the ones
that come up more than once for like
alright yeah
and the answers are anonymized gives
people another layer of permission to be
particularly direct and one thing that
came up for me and it's actually the
only thing that I remember because I
literally could not read this document
uh-huh I mean I went through it once and
I was like I can't yeah
actually psychologically digest all this
right now but I did pay attention to a
few things and one that came up a lot
and then I want to I want to come
straight back to you but this this may
be helpful for other people if they
choose to implement something of it like
this even with their friends and they
know that they're doing just look up the
360 review and you'll find all sorts of
resources I've never seen Tim fully
celebrate anything and it relates back
to what I mentioned earlier is always
looking for what's wrong yeah this stuff
takes care of itself we're only doing
our jobs I'm only doing my job why would
I pat myself on the back for doing
something that I signed up to do yes it
would be a disappointment not to do it I
don't get extra credit for completing
something and that became so severe and
maybe it relates to a lot of other stuff
that I'll talk about another time but
feeling damaged or in some way flawed or
undeserving of that but I in retrospect
very painful pill to swallow but they
were absolutely right I mean it's crazy
to think mm-hmm but at a certain point
and I don't expect anyone to cry me a
river on this stuff but it does belie
some type of real psychological issue
that I had your address but I remember
the last two times I've had a book do
very well on the bestseller lists I mean
when like the first time it happened
like game-changing claps against the
wall fall on the floor I can't believe
it dazed for the rest of the day maybe
the rest of the week on cloud nine and
at this point I feel like it's the
expectation that my books will do that
certainly it's the expectation of the
publishers yep and it's it's just relief
that I didn't fail mm-hmm and maybe I'll
have one drink and then it's like all
right on to whatever you should be doing
next
mm-hmm that's awful so it may be good I
mean obviously from a most great product
people are perpetually dissatisfied with
their product but it is I mean first of
all yo yeah it's not good for your own
psyche but for people around you you
know they can start to see that as
also you know a form of arrogance or you
know you in some ways you're getting a
gratification that most people will
never be able to get and then they're
seeing you not acknowledge it it's
interesting again like back to that mere
exercise unexpected things you might see
yeah that people say yeah for sure and
also I mean I least in my own reflection
the voice in my head that has been in my
head that we assumed to be us is very
often for me not my voice at all it's
the it's the maybe hyper critical voice
of other people I was around huh yes and
have adopted but for I'm playing their
soundtrack yes I did not decide to have
that voice and also realizing that how I
talk to myself even silently is very
often how even indirectly I end up
communicating with other people I think
it's just through body language or
implied and you know you can help other
people to help yourself or you can help
yourself to help other people but super
super valuable so I'm glad you brought
up the exercise and I'm gonna I'm going
to publicly on the podcast verse I'm
gonna suggest that we tap out and go sit
outside risk oh thank god yeah so we
were going to say don't have the
physique of Tim for those who can see it
doesn't seem to help with my my pep talk
so we're gonna we're gonna keep
recording and just walk out would be
helpful to have a temperature gauge of
some sort which we do not have and now
we're outside so you'll get to listen to
the wildlife in the middle of the night
in the countryside which is nice
stars stars fire pit so we can so be
mastered setting this would be the third
setting we're doing a lot of a lot of
costume changes and a lot of scenery
shifts this is good you know I think
that crickets insects and birds at night
is a perfect setting for product talk
my favorite where shall we begin you
know I think that product and when I use
product I mean any kind of customer
experience your crafting whether it's a
service an in-store experience if you're
a retail store owner or a digital
product right and I think that there's
some big counterintuitive and strange
ironies in how how we craft products and
experiences for people first of all we
have way too much faith in people
unearthing the value of what we're
building and and what I always like to
remind myself and teams that I work with
is that in the first 30 seconds of any
experience of a new product service
experience whatever every customer is
lazy vain and selfish they're lazy in
the sense that they don't want to read
anything that I want to watch videos
they don't to try to figure out how
something works they're vain in the
sense that admitted you know let's all
admit we all have ego we all want to
feel good about ourselves and something
that makes us look better to ourselves
into others feeds that and I don't think
any of us are immune from feeling that
to some degree and selfish in this sense
that hey I have so little capacity and I
want to look I want to I want to achieve
a lot very quickly
an example on the selfish side is
products like like stripe or or Twilio
or others that kind of appeal to
developers with hey two lines of code as
a way of that adopting that technology
because it was just like hey it's
selfish like it just I'm gonna get this
done quickly I don't even care if it's
as good as like the homegrown solution
and and you know vanity comes across in
every consumer product you see with
those ego analytics those hearts those
things that tell you that oh wow like
it's working I want to do this more and
and of course laziness you see with
every onboarding of every product we go
through and and so with that boarding
meaning the signup process exactly the
signup process or walking into the store
knowing when you when you go into any
product experience why are you there
where do you go next what's possible
now the pushback I get from a lot of
great you know companies and teams
whatever is hey I have more faith in
people you know they're gonna figure out
why this product is great I can appeal
to them with this long-term value of
what they have to contribute I mean you
look at a product a Pinterest again
which was really ultimately a network of
discovery but their appeal in the early
stages of their business was just make a
quick collection that's visual as
opposed to delicious which was just
links you know so they appeal to that
like immediate need of I want a
collection for myself before recognizing
the value of other people's content and
it's just there's so many examples of
teams you know there another you know
product thing I think a lot about is
back to that kind of onboarding first
time user experience is um you know
should you make a video of how to use
your product should you walk people
through and tell them they can read
something or if you just do it for them
and a lot of a lot of products that
really do succeed quickly actually give
you like a template they just like
actually do it for you they make you
seem so much better than you are with
stock content or whatever it is so
there's just like a few examples around
the edges but it's a but it to me it's a
product principle that um that makes the
case that we have to spend a ton of time
on crafting that first mile experience
for our customers how do you use stress
test say a first design
after you've assuming the team has
accepted those Commandments or those
realities and they they think they've
designed for it how do you stress test
it well there's a few on there there's
there's first of all the classic metrics
of our people getting their way through
what's catch what's catching them up you
know I remember in the behance days we
had a terminology for the creative field
that you're in called realms and we
realized people didn't understand what
that meant and so that was an insight in
the first mile experience that
drastically improved conversion you know
the little things like that but I think
that a but it really comes down to
empathy with the the newest user are you
bringing people in and watching them on
a computer or are you using a contracted
service some type of online service to
record Craig
list we're doing all of the above I
think great teams first of all don't
outsource this completely they recognize
that only being shoulder to shoulder
with their newest customers and I'll get
to the newest customer why I keep saying
that in a second is crucial because
you're kind of feeling the anxiety in
the pain where every port or some graph
will never really tell you the the the
and yeah like I mean I think that
there's a lot of mechanisms to measure
the effectiveness of a first mile the
the thing is though it's actually not as
simple as just solving it like once you
have a new product in the world and call
it Twitter right you have you launch
Twitter and you appeal to a group of
users that are actually willing to build
their timeline follow all the accounts
and over a period of time have a great
experience that is a cohort of new users
then word gets out people start to use
Twitter who you know kind of come for
the news as an alternative to CNN and
they're hit over the head with this idea
of building your timeline following
accounts and they're like what I don't
you know I don't have the tolerance for
that and in this instance think about it
like they could have nailed their first
mile and had tremendous growth and then
suddenly the newest cohort of new users
isn't even willing to go through it and
they have to completely kind of reinvent
the first mile experience of their
product which is why teams have to
continually like kind of reinvent that
for a smile it's not like you get it
right and then it's like move on which
actually most teams do mm-hmm
and so that that then relates to the
newest customer paying attention to the
latest cohort is that that's the
reference yeah it's it's consistently
committing period of time to
understanding who the newest customers
are I mean think about it the newest
ones are the first ones you ever have
when you launch a product are super
forgiving they're early adopters the
next round you know they're they're
actually like a little bit more about
this better be professional this better
be reliable but they're you know they're
willing to go and go along with some
bugs and whatever you know eventually
you get to those kind of pragmatist
right later in the curve and and you you
now the other problem that a lot of
teams have is that when they're
launching their product let's
talk about the newest of the new users
when you first launch a product
oftentimes ironically the last smile of
their experience building the product is
spent on the first mile of the customers
experience of the product it sounds like
you're done with building probably after
two years or whatever and it's like oh
we got to make a tour and Oh what
should the default to be when customers
come in our friend Dave Marin who's you
know another great product thinker
always likes to say the devil's in the
default whatever customers see first
they're just gonna stick with forever
that kind of decision can't be made like
right before a launch in fact that's the
most important decision you're gonna
make
yeah yeah definitely what advice do you
give to entrepreneurs when they have say
two or three products that they feel
torn between and they don't know which
direction to go in and they say I feel
like we would be equally happy yes doing
a or B but once we commit we know we're
going to be on this path for a good
chunk of time and it's gonna chew up a
lot of resources yeah how do I choose
well I think that there's there's two
answers to that you know one is is you
print out comps for both like designs
and you put them in front of customers
and you're sort of getting a sense of
meaning mock mock get mock-ups sorry and
and you you you test you build some of
the marketing copy like welcoming you
just give give like a design and
experience a fake experience and you
test that and you you gauge what what
sort of approach to this problem
resonates with people you know I think
that a common mistake at this phase is
that teams decide to focus on the thing
they're most passionate about solving or
the solution that they're most
passionate about I'm rather than seeking
more and more empathy with the person
suffering the problem and so you'll be
like oh my god this is the best solution
like I'm so passionate let's do it which
is why I always actually say that
empathy is more important than passion
and when it comes to like figuring out
what product you should actually do also
in the question of how you determine
which product to build when your team
comes together and you're trying to
solve a problem listen there's a lot of
talk about the the notion of a lean
startup and getting an MVP or Minimum
Viable
a product out there and testing I mean
that's another answer to your question
right not only do you make up mock-ups
and show people and test how the
marketing company and the value
proposition of what you're building yes
put out a product and see how it
performs but the problem with that that
teams I think run into is that whatever
you ship ends up having more sticking
power for your own team's approach and a
bit and becomes a bit of a local Maxima
of what you're able to do after so this
notion of hey we'll ship a Minimum
Viable version and then we'll just
iterate to a great place so what was the
word you used local in the local maximum
is high schoo you're anchored you're
anchored right to that version of the
product in some way and and whatever
iterations you say you're going to be
able to do to actually get to that
elusive product market fit where
suddenly customers are getting the value
out of it enough to tell their friends
the it actually make it harder to beat
it to get there when you're not willing
to do very bold strokes and so so I
think in an ideal world you do some
testing before you start building of
just the the idea showing the mock-ups
the stuff we discussed earlier but then
you build something that you truly
believe has a shot at adding that or
delivering that value to customers and
take the extra time to perfect the few
differentiating factors that are like
most special about it yes you can cut
corners around all the other edges but
you don't want to ship the Minimum
Viable version of the thing that you're
going to be known for because that's not
going to test whether or not the
conviction you have is the right one in
the the minimal Viable Product also is
at least in my mind and I'm sure I'm
missing plenty predicated on a number of
different things it is much more
appropriate for software than many other
types of products that you might show
because it can be at least at this point
I'm not always the case but iterated and
updated remotely a second even within
software it applies most I would say to
products that are a unique solution
to a pressing problem people will put up
with a lot of and a lot of bugs
and a lot of heavy lifting if you are
the only option yes but if on the other
hand you are say a newsletter of a
certain type or you have in fact a very
attractive market but also very
competent competition yeah I that
approach may not always be yeah the best
approach the minimum viable experience
of a restaurant you know but at the end
of the day you also don't need to get
everything right to launch right or to
open your doors what you do need to get
right is the thing you're going to be
known for the last thing I would say on
the product side right yeah is is
actually let's talk about you know
another mutual friend of ours
Garrett camp who is a co-founder of a
number of different companies and and
and actually not including some big ones
including some big ones like uber and he
you know one of the things that uh that
I have learned from him over the years
and I've seen in some other you know
serial successful founders is this
notion of building the narrative before
the product so and we were just talking
about which product do you choose
sometimes it actually helps to say hey
what is what what should the splash page
be and what should the brand be before
we even get the team together I mean get
alone start building something or coding
something in a digital sense we talked
about the notion of product market fit
right when when customers are getting
the value we talked about the notion of
product founder fit when you find the
right team to build something what about
product brand fit what about making sure
that you have like something that's
piercing I remember when Garrett was
thinking about uber originally when he
was still just CEO of his company
StumbleUpon he was kind of drafting out
the concept of uber and and I remember
him obsessing over the icon yeah like
the logo before there was even a team or
a CEO
on this project I also remember him
agonizing over this notion of hey is it
do you is it an aspirational brand like
everyone's private driver or is it an
accessible brand like taxis on demand
right and I mean if you think about that
it's like wow like these are questions
that he was asking before this was this
technology was even coming together or
even validate it right
yeah carrot is if is a very exceptional
human and founder who really telescopes
out very very far in the earliest stages
and I remember getting one of the very
very early mock-ups this was this was
before the app was deployed even with
one car the screenshots you know these
these comps as you mentioned the the
looks like model in a number of graphics
that he sent to me and the streets were
in the Netherlands and I was like wait
what he was thinking global think global
he was but it's also though I've had
conversation with him about brands for
other companies that he's you know been
working on and and he'll say he's really
all about buying great domain names as
you know and come here but they create
pithy hopefully four-letter brands and
and I asked him about that in the
process of putting the book for the
messy middle together and he was saying
that um it's also about what kind of
email address the team that you put
together will actually want to have I
was like you know address like why does
that matter he was like would you rather
have a you know Scott at spot.com would
you rather have Scott at Discoverer
spot.com
you know and and so he was also thinking
about from like the product brand fit
perspective is this something that
people can grow into that people would
want to work at and say like I work this
is my email address so I just I've
always been fascinated by the fact that
he develops this narrative and like that
brand development piece even before the
product and in some cases the team it's
and again back to that question you
originally asked of which product do I
build where do I start which I get from
founders all the time I actually like to
say and I even do this internally in my
day job at Adobe now with new products
that are being developed around the
company put together the splash page and
it's like well I don't even know what
it's gonna be called yeah I don't know
what the brand will be I don't know what
the slogan will be I don't know what
that and it's like yes
boy that's the point like put that
together as a starting place because it
you know it helps get alignment very
quickly which is a magical part of
product development is when you have
alignment versus not two different two
different ball games so you look at that
chapter one and then flash forward or
not yet two epilogue but if we're
looking at the end game I mean to use
chess chess parlance and they in the
chess sense not in the objective sense
so I guess they're kind of the same in
some respects what is what is one lesson
/ story / maksim that you could share
right well you've even endured a very
volatile journey you've optimized
everything that works along the way with
your product with your team with
yourself and then it's like wow I seen
an insight
it could be listen things end in great
ways or bad ways whether it's a shutdown
of something whether it's a launch of
something whether it's an acquisition
whether it's going public and there's
also of course like many finishes along
the way right and any major in any
journey but I really I think that the
this notion of the final mile of
something is very interesting to me
because it's an entirely different sport
the stuff that you were so good at to
get to this point of hopefully success
is a completely different playbook than
what you need to do to manage the
decisions at the end and in this context
the end are we talking primarily about
acquisition or IPO let's talk about that
first although I think that some of this
is relevant across other sorts of
finishes as well but a few things happen
I mean first of all you with the
confidence that you've built throughout
the journey of getting there
you start to make decisions that you
actually don't have the expertise nor
experience to to make I remember getting
a call from a founder maybe like four or
five months ago who was telling me that
um that he was really excited that one
of these big kind of Google Facebook
like companies was doing their diligence
on his on his on his company I was like
oh wow that's really exciting where are
you in the process he's like well you
know they've come in and met the team
like oh they've met the team so you must
have an offer on the table like what you
know what's the value how is this gonna
work
and he said oh no no we haven't gotten
there yet I was like wait so you had
them come in and meet your team and you
don't even know is this a talent
acquisition is this uh is this something
you would do or not do like how could
you suddenly expose so much of who the
people are and what you're doing at
everything and as the conversation
unraveled you know he realized he had no
idea what he was doing yeah and you know
him it was like business as usual and
you know that's one example where that
final mile you know is an entirely
different sport but I think the I think
that the the other thing that happens
that's really interesting is that people
psychologically start to wonder you know
whether they deserve what their the
success they're about to get I remember
a story and my in my own experience with
the hints there was a member of senior
member of my team who right towards the
acquisition was starting to behave
somewhat erratically like was doing
things at team meetings that were kind
of offensive to people and that were
kind of on the line of and starting to
act out a lot and I remember confronting
him a couple times and he would kind of
blow it off like oh yeah whatever but it
kept happening and I was just fascinated
by this and I remember going home to my
wife one evening who's a psychologist
and talking her about it and she was
like oh he's you know this is
self-sabotage like what like he's been
working his whole life for something
like this we're about to have this big
payday and this big celebration like why
would he and and and she kind of helped
me understand when you don't feel like
you
deserve something or when there's other
sorts of parts of you that are not
comfortable with like what's happening
you can subconsciously sabotage yourself
so I came in to work the next day and
herds the end of the day when people
were going out of the office was getting
late I pulled him into the corner of a
conference room where it was kind of not
visible and I sat down with him and I
kind of leaned over and I was like you
deserved this he's like what what are
you talking about like this is okay that
you deserve this this is gonna work out
and in that conversation he kind of
started tearing it was one of those
moments where I think I think he was at
first like what the hell are you talking
about and then kind of there was this
connection we had where um where he sort
of looked at his behavior as maybe
something else and and I think that
happens a lot I think that there is this
things do break down in the final mile a
lot of stuff changes psychologically
artists right how much churn happens
right before they ship I'm you've
published multiple books like how many
times right before it's done you're like
wait wait maybe I should've done
something else maybe I should cut this
piece whatever and that's like by a
class of behavior in every product
release there's always this period that
we call kind of last-minute turn where
it's like wait a second not ready to
ship yet so this is a classic and you
have to be prepared for it yeah I mean
overriding typically comes in I mean
there's a point where you lose as a
writer at least so much perspective on
the writing you have put down because
it's been through 17 drafts or 374
drafts you no longer have a tether to
objectivity yes and yet you know that
there are probably things that could be
improved
still you start to fuss yeah with in
many cases no particular direction or
means of assessing your changes but you
know there are things to be fixed or
improved upon that imagine it happens in
a whole lot of contexts I think it does
and I mean last-minute jitters before
wedding I mean who knows I mean some of
which might well-founded not saying
that's you know you should ignore your
spider sense but common and I think that
so then the question is so how do you
make sure you have a successful final
model and I think I think part
it is starting to be alert of a lot of
these tendencies that creep up right
before shipping right before being done
right before being acquired or whatever
it is and part of it is recognizing that
the tactics that you employed all along
suddenly may either be wrong or even
detrimental it's it's really this is a
new game and you have to kind of take a
step back you have to get new different
types of mentors and help and help I
mean literally I mean when I was going
through my acquisition there's a guy
named Chris Dixon who's a great investor
who was an angel in my in my company and
he was the guy that was up with me at
what does it when have one in the
morning I mean I remember those nights
where he was helping me go through the
cat table of our team and making sure
that I was thinking about it properly
and and and I realized in that process I
had no idea what I was doing I needed
different types of help for different
types of questions and then there's the
other kind of more existential thing
that happens at the end of a project
which is suddenly especially if it's
successful you it becomes part of your
identity you become kind of known for
something and you start to you have to
decide like is that is that going to be
me or am I going to start to reject that
and put it behind me and you'll you'll
talk about you'll hear some creatives
and especially artists say that they
just like to kill their old work you
know is they like to do something
completely different otherwise they feel
like they're attached I know authors who
won't speak about their past books
because it's just like they gotta move
past that in a frame of mind but that
realization that you know you are not
your work being able to disconnect and
disassociate when it's appropriate is
another challenge in that final mile
yeah super challenging I mean that's
making you think of my first and second
book I mean I could have done the
three-and-a-half hour work week right
Quora milked the 4-hour workweek plus
before I could have milked that thing
but I I was I was really afraid of
having to give the same talk email
autoresponders until my dying day yeah
as much as we would all like email to
die I don't think it's gonna happen
anytime soon
I say I made the it was not an easy
decision for me but because I had no
evidence that I would be able to write
about a different topic yeah he was my
first book and but ultimately made the
decision that I could always go back to
the well mm-hmm
if I ended up deserving it meaning if
the 4-hour workweek was was not going to
disappear after a year if I deserved it
and was still here in two years three
years four years I could go back to it
but that I had to do something different
so that I didn't develop a defensive
nough surround protecting that as my
identity and then correspondingly
develop a risk intolerance to trying
something different
mm-hmm but that was hard
this isn't it's and it's also if you
look at it from a business perspective
there's every reason to make a sequel
and to you know squeeze the value out of
anything that works when you look at it
from an art perspective you that's the
opposite and I think that that's
actually I think the greatest founders
out there you know recognize that you
all the you know the the science of
business is scaling everything that you
can and automating and whatever the art
of business is the things that don't
scale and and it's you know and and they
see their their career in that way as
well it's like I'm not just gonna be the
enterprise SAS guy I'm not going to be
the this I'm not going to be the that
I'm gonna actually kind of find another
edge find something different keep it
fresh and yeah that's that's admirable
because it's you know it's it's not that
it's not the path of least resistance
well I think that life business arts you
pick it is is very often not the path of
least resistance there are arguments to
be made for both but you will regardless
end up having to deal with circumstances
outside of your control problems that
couldn't have been predicted new
circumstances that require you to adapt
and maybe to grope around like a person
in the dark for a period of time with
great discomfort and we've been talking
about some of your lessons learned
the story's based on experiences you've
had and that you've had imparted to you
from mentors you have taken all of these
notes those that made the final cut
what is it 120 just about and I'm
looking at this compendium in front of
me kind of a choose-your-own-adventure
guide with in the buckets that we spoke
about so what what is this that I'm
looking at it appears to be a book I
think you alluded to it may be mentioned
it once this is the messy middle
subtitle this is the final subtitle this
is the fine no no no that's fine I just
before I read it I want to make sure
finding your way through the hardest and
most crucial part of any bold venture
and I have well I thought I was because
I've had a chance to read it I've had a
chance to kind of live through you
hearing many of these stories and
thrilled that you are sharing them where
can people learn more about the book
yeah I think the need is clear I'm
excited about it it's um you know it's
as you said I it really was that process
of 800 and something notes down to the
you know ended the 300 down to the two
and Johnna the 120 organized in these
kind of three can the themes we talked
about tonight endurance optimization the
final mile the messy middle really is
this passionate side project I've had
for the last five or so years I'm
excited to get it out there coming out
hits shelves October 2nd at 2018 and and
and then I'm trying to also though like
continue these as conversations you know
on Twitter I'm at just a Scott Belsky
and and frankly a lot of the stuff we
talked tonight are things that I've also
shared over the years and tested and
gotten feedback on and incorporated into
ultimately you know what this book has
become so I think that uh we're all in
our own messy middles and we think and I
just hope that this you know this this
helps people know that they're not alone
as they're in the enduring enduring
phase and managing the volatility I hope
it helps them mine it a little bit more
productively I hope it helps people
build better products that all of us can
benefit from and optimize anything else
that's working
within their team and and when it comes
down to that final mile let's not screw
it up let's ship here here well Scott
thanks for the endurance of this
marathon across multiple types of
scenery within certain types of scenery
I'm gonna lie as defense at different
temperatures maybe in some ways like the
messy middle and everybody listening
thanks for being a fly on the wall and
also accepting this experimental format
and you can find links to anything we
might have talked about some of the
people we mentioned the founders and
their products companies and so on in
the show notes as per usual at tim dot
blog forward slash podcast and until
next time as always thank you so very
much for listening I love doing this and
you guys make it possible
so what through the internet to all of
you until next time
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
for me every Friday event provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of weird that I've
somehow dug up in the the world of the
esoteric
as I do it could include favorite
articles that I have read and that I've
shared with my close friends for
instance and it's very short it's just a
little tiny bite of goodness before you
head off for the weekend so if you want
to receive that check it out just go to
4-hour workweek dot-com that's 4-hour
workweek com all spelled out and just
drop in if your email and you'll get the
very next one and if you sign up I hope
you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
LegalZoom which more than 2 million
Americans have used to help start their
businesses past guests even such as
while WordPress lead developer CEO of
automatic Matt Mullenweg now valued at
more than a billion dollars have used
LegalZoom to help with their business
needs specifically in his case to to
form his company but LegalZoom isn't
just for launching your business their
services include everything from helping
you to manage changing tax laws
reviewing contracts creating any das
non-disclosure agreements important
stuff handling lease agreements and
assisting with really any other legal
challenge hurdle inconvenience that
typically takes time and effort away
from running your business the best part
is that you won't get charged by the
hour
because Leal zoom isn't a law firm so
they won't be running the clock up and
spinning circles just to raise your bill
instead they just ask you to pay one low
upfront price for whatever it is that
you're looking to get Alucard style
so visit legalzoom.com and check out
their business section for all of their
services and if you want special savings
that's the terminology and the copy that
they suggest I don't know what the
special savings is folks but it's
titillating if you want special savings
enter promo code Tim T I am at checkout
capital T lower case I am again take
peak legalzoom.com and enter promo code
Tim this episode is brought to you by
fresh books fresh books has become the
go-to cloud accounting software for
literally millions of small business
owners who found a faster more efficient
and much less stressful way to deal with
their numbers and ultimately this helps
you to focus on what you are best at it
is used by many of the fastest growing
startups I've invested in or advise and
it's equally used by many of the best
freelancers I work with on a daily or
weekly basis it is one of the easiest
ways to send invoices get paid and track
your time and track your clients if
you're self-employed and managing
business sometimes means wrestling with
spreadsheets crumpled receipts and other
scattered pieces fresh books can really
help fresh books allows you to do many
many different things very easily
preparing and sending a polished branded
invoice takes about 30 second
you can set yourself up to receive
online payments from your clients in
about two clicks which on average will
get you paid twice as fast their new
proposals feature means you can include
a project summary and timeline as part
of your estimate there are many many
other things
tracking your time the quick proposals
that I mentioned formatting free
super-easy late payment reminders so
you'll have to chase people automatic
expenses sharing files and messages with
your clients award-winning customer
service they are extremely responsive
the interface is super intuitive and
there's almost no learning curve so in
short it's easy it saves you time and
right now fresh books is offering an
unrestricted 30-day free trial for all
of my listeners to claim yours check it
out go to FreshBooks dot-com forward
slash tim and enter tim ferriss in the
how did you hear about a section and
that is funky spell t IM f e RR is s so
again go fresh books comm forward slash
tim and enter tim ferriss and how did
you hear about us section check it out
you